what does or does not count as a POI
flower petal
what's the fewest number of petals you
can have
is a cat eye a flower
these are all actually deceptively
difficult questions to answer and cause
a lot of debate amongst POI Spinners
even to this day but why the controversy
and is there any way to resolve it
drexier from drexfactor POI sharing with
you the love of poi spinning and flow
Arts to benefit your body and brain in
this video we're going to dive into the
very messy math of flowers to see if we
can't get some answers but before we
dive in I want to give a quick shout out
to the Friends of the channel big thanks
to dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links I've got down in the
description of this video and a special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lei machinsky and
Becca beckonen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission so first up it's probably
going to help for us to talk about what
exactly a POI flower is let alone a
flower petal POI flowers were first
popularized by Nick Woolsey his video
dervishly yours introduced the flow Arts
world to his approach to this concept
and it became an overnight sensation
Nick himself saw the concept as being an
extension of what we do when we play
around with a toy called a spirograph
drawing complex patterns over time that
would overlap in a series of round
figures with different numbers of Loops
in mathematics these types of curves are
known as roulettes with two individual
subcategories that should be very
familiar to anyone who has ever played
with POI flowers the first of these
categories are epitrokoids and they
correspond roughly to the POI flowers
that we refer to as in-spin that is poi
flowers in which the POI and hands spend
in the same direction in the same plane
the second category are hypotropoids and
they correspond roughly to anti-spin POI
flowers these are flowers in which the
POI and the hands spin in opposite
directions in the same plane now please
note epitrocoids and hypotropoids are
specific terms for types of curves that
have unique mathematical identities they
resemble in spin and anti-spin flowers
closely enough that we can use them to
model the behavior of poi flowers but
aren't Bound by the same real world
constraints that POI are so while useful
they are not quite the same thing I'll
confess that I don't actually know who
it was that first referred to these POI
patterns as flowers they certainly have
plenty of antecedents in traditional
Maori POI spinning as well as Club
swinging but I can't find any reference
in literature about either art to a
trick or move referred to as a flower
but flowers they became and with them
the nomenclature of referring to the
loops those shapes produce as petals and
a whole lot of epistemological grief in
the process too for many of the early
flowers it was simple and kind of
obvious to refer to the closed Loops
produced by these patterns as being
petals where inspin flowers would be
characterized by broad round petals that
pointed inward towards the center of the
performer and anti-spin flowers by
narrow sharper petals that pointed
outward away from the center of the
performer early on four petal flowers of
both in-spin and anti-spin varieties
were quite popular and eventually three
petal anti-spin flowers or tricetras
gain favor as well at one point Nick
Woolsey himself referred to tri-cetras
as being the anti-spin flowers with the
fewest number of petals and he would
know right
right
well I remember thinking when Nick
woolsey's Video on tricetras came out
that there was something weird about
this but I couldn't quite put my finger
on what and then a couple years later a
couple friends uploaded videos of
themselves performing some tricks and
among them were some cat eyes they
referred to their cat eyes as being one
petal anti-spin flowers and goodness the
comments section went wild why the
controversy let's take a look at several
flowers to get a rough idea here are a
four petal in spin flower and a four
petal anti-spin flower visually they
definitely function as mirror images of
each other if we were to work our way
down to three petal inspin flowers and
three petal anti-spin flowers there's
likewise a good match here in terms of
their appearance there are three very
clear Loops created in each pattern now
for simplicity's sake let's skip down to
just a single pedal for each that's not
hard to imagine for an inspin flower
given the petals kind of Nest inside of
a larger Circle but how exactly do we
get the feel of an anti-spin flower with
only a single petal looking at a cat eye
it's not hard to make that leap and just
to offer up a point of clarity because I
know someone is going to make a thing
about it in the comments normally when
we perform POI flowers we're doing so
with the hand moving around a circle
that is two POI lengths in diameter
whereas with cat eyes the hand is moving
around a circle that is only one POI
length in diameter why the change when
we try to perform cations with a hand
path that is two POI lengths in diameter
we basically just wind up with a
straight line or linear isolation this
doesn't look particularly interesting
and is incredibly difficult to perform
so we usually shrink down the hand path
both to create a pattern that has a more
recognizable appearance and is
significantly easier to perform so all
that said we get that long narrow loop
we're used to seeing from anti-spin
flowers and the POI in hand are
definitely spinning in opposite
directions
seems like it would make sense right
well hang on a sec
what about those two petal flowers that
we skipped a two petal inspin flower
isn't really that hard to conceptualize
again the petals are nested within a
larger shape so we can simply put two
petals across from each other and we get
there pretty easily but how do we get
two anti-spin pedals how do we get those
two narrow Loops that we're used to
seeing something like this figure eight
looks like it could be a good fit but
there's a problem it's actually
impossible to do this with POI because
there are segments of it in which we'd
have to be pushing the POI head to the
side when it was swinging upward and
gravity makes that impossible
so it was a two petal anti-spin flower
even possible maybe let's take another
look at these flowers from a slightly
different perspective I know we've been
focusing on petals as being those
enclosed Loops in the Poise path but
what if instead we changed our framing
of them so bear with me here what makes
those Loops possible is the POI swinging
across the path of the hand in in spin
flowers the POI crosses from outside the
hand path to inside the hand path and
back out again in anti-spin flowers the
POI crosses from inside the hand path to
outside of it to create those Loops so
what if we use this definition instead
for flower petals fortunately that
doesn't change anything about our four
petal flowers or our three petal flowers
but our two petal flowers well now when
we look at that cat eye we see the POI
cross over the path of the hand twice so
looking at flowers through this lens a
cat eye becomes a two petal anti-spin
flower instead of a one petal anti-spin
flower okay so which approach is the
right way of looking at it well honestly
I think neither of them because I think
that there's a flaw inherent in the
formulation of this question to
understand why though I'm going to need
to ask you to look at this through a
completely different lens as I perform a
four petal inspin flower I want you to
take a moment to notice how many
downbeats I perform with the POI that is
how many times the POI head passes
directly underneath my hand I count one
two three four five downbeats as I go
around one at each side and two at the
bottom wait a sec two at the bottom why
is that in simplest terms inspin flowers
Nest small circles inside of a larger
Circle so the total number of downbeats
is equal to the number of beats in each
individual Circle one for each of the
smaller circles plus one for the big one
that they're nested inside of now how
about for the four petal anti-spin
flower this time I count one two three
beats all told one left one bottom and
one right there is no downbeat under
that top pedal what's up with that so
this is definitely going to be a bit of
an oversimplification but for our
purposes it'll work when we're creating
anti-spin flowers we're kind of cutting
up bigger circles into smaller pieces
that we then glue back together at the
tip of every flower petal so if you
imagine for a moment that we spin the
POI three quarters of a circle between
the tip of each flower petal that means
we're adding up four different segments
that are three quarters of a circle long
3 times 4 is 12 and 12 divided by 4 that
gets us to a total of three circles
weird right and speaking of if we Zoom
back out for a second and compare the
inspin flower to the anti-spin flower
things get even weirder why is it for
inspin and anti-spin flowers with the
same number of petals the inspin flower
has one more downbeat than the total
number of petals and the anti-spin
flower has one fewer downbeat what's
going on here the key to this mismatch
is recognizing that we are trying to
describe two very different approaches
to graphing these shapes when we count
petals what we're doing is keeping track
of an object as it moves Inward and then
back out away from a center point this
type of graph uses what are known as
Polar coordinates when we count down
beats on the other hand we're keeping
track of an object as it oscillates
along vertical and horizontal axes this
type of graph uses what are known as
Cartesian coordinates now each of these
coordinate systems work and both can
definitely model what happens in POI
flowers but I'll confess I am a little
bit more partial to one than the other
and I'll tell you why when we use
Cartesian coordinates it orients our
understanding of the graph in line with
what we experience in a space where
gravity is in play going up and down a
y-axis corresponds to going up and down
in real space too and it helps explain
something pretty important about how we
create hybrids if you've ever tried to
perform a four petal in spin flower with
one hand and a four petal anti-spin
flower with the other you know that this
has to be a poly Rhythm hybrid there's a
difference of two beats between the two
patterns and thus you cycle through
different timing and Direction modes
continuously if on the other hand you
perform a two petal in spin flower with
a four petal anti-spin flower you're now
performing two flower patterns that each
have three downbeats and the timing and
Direction remains consistent this is way
easier and more intuitive than the other
option so counting flower petals is
inherently tricky both because we don't
have a clear definition for what a petal
is nor are we describing a phenomenon
that lines up terribly well with what
our experience is in winning the POI and
there have been a couple attempts to try
and make all of these pieces make sense
one of the first that I encountered was
actually a system that alien John
invented that shifts Focus once again to
something that I'd never even thought to
examine in this system we spend so much
time looking at these POI tricks in
terms of the patterns and paths that
they create that we frequently forget
that those patterns exist mostly in our
own heads but what doesn't is the
relationship between the hand and the
POI let me show you something really
interesting that happens if we look at
individual moments in a four petal
inspin flower rather than trying to see
the overall pattern if I pause the
movement of the hand and POI at the tip
of a flower petal notice how the trails
they leave behind point in opposite
directions
if on the other hand I paused the
movement of the two in between two
petals the trails they leave behind
point in the same direction all right so
this one might take a little bit of work
to wrap your head around but think of it
this way even though the POI and the
hand are moving in the same direction in
a global frame of reference because one
is orbiting the other we can narrow our
scope down to find moments where
relative to each other they're moving in
parallel and moments when they're moving
in opposite directions this same
property exists in anti-spin flowers too
again if I pause the movement of the POI
and the hand at the tip of a flower
petal the trails they leave behind
reveal that they are spinning in
opposite directions in this moment and
if I pause the movement to the POI in
the hand in between two petals the
trails reveal them moving in the same
direction what we're doing here is
playing around with what are called
vectors in mathematics and physics and
more specifically movement vectors John
labeled the movements when the POI in
hand have opposite vectors as loops and
moments when the POI in hand and have
parallel vectors as arcs now what will
really noodle your Noggin is that we can
get shapes wherein the POI is
permanently locked into a loop and
shapes when the POI is permanently
locked into an arc as well these are
isolations and extensions respectively
and that is a story for another time but
before your brain is fully cooked I do
want to explore just one last attempt to
model flowers because I think ultimately
it offers up the most comprehensive
answer for what all the flowers wind up
looking like this is a method devised by
Charlie Cushing of Nine Square theory of
Fame when he noticed something kind of
interesting about the relationship
between petals and downbeats so the
first thing to understand about this is
that we're going to use a math equation
to produce our flower patterns using
Cartesian coordinates
I know that this looks like gibberish if
you haven't brushed up on your
trigonometry lately so I'll give you the
Cliff's Notes this set of terms right
here governs the movement of the hand
while this set governs the movement of
the POI this variable B controls the
number of Beats our POI are producing
for every beat that the hand completes
and if I make b a negative number the
resulting pattern will be an anti-spin
if you'd like a more thorough
explanation as to how this math and this
equation Works leave me a comment and
I'll produce a video just on that topic
alone now let's start off by revisiting
our old friend the four petal inspin
flower we already know that it has a
total of five downbeats so B here is
equal to five I'm going to go ahead and
create a new graph and track the
relationship between downbeats and
petals I'm going to say that my x-axis
is the number of downbeats and my y-axis
is the number of flower petals and mark
down my first point at five comma four
I'm going to make b equal to 4 now and
that's going to result in a three petal
inspin flower so I'll mark down my next
point at four comma three now I'll make
be equal to 3 and the result will be a
two petal inspin flower mark down the
next point at three comma two and we're
ready for our next entry here I'll make
b equal to two and we wind up with a one
petal in spin flower as I mark down two
comma one on the graph do you notice how
a pattern or slope is emerging here I'll
go ahead and set b equal to one and now
what comes out is simply an extension
and this makes sense the slope we were
seeing emerging would suggest that we
would wind up with a pattern with zero
petals and an extension surely does not
have any petals to it now just for grins
let's say we came in from the opposite
side to see where the two ends meet I'll
go ahead and start by setting b equal to
negative five so five downbeats but the
POI is spinning the opposite direction
as the hand in a global frame of
reference this results in a six petal
anti-spin flower pretty cool let's mark
down negative five negative six we set b
equal to negative four and we get a five
petal anti-spin and negative three we
have 4 petals negative two we have three
petals and sure enough that cat eye or
linear isolation emerges at negative one
as having two petals but is there a one
petal anti-spin that emerges from this
picture well
sort of it sure looks like we just need
to make b equal to zero and that should
give us a one petal anti-spin flower
right well here's what happens when I do
that at first glance this may look like
a pendulum but a pendulum will swing to
either side as it goes around this
pattern would only be possible with a
rigid prop like a club you'll also
notice there are no moments when the
movement Vector of the POI and the hand
are opposite each other so there are no
Loops to this pattern so can we really
call this a one petal anti-spin flower
it's probably stretching things a bit
but at the very least it's completely
consistent with one approach to breaking
down this problem if you don't think
that this is a particularly satisfying
answer though I don't blame you it's
also worth noting here that Charlie has
a completely different way of framing
the idea of petals rather than even
trying to count moments when the POI
path loops around in different ways
Charlie instead counts moments with the
POI passing inside of the hand path
labeling them lobes and moments where
the POI passes outside the hand path
labeling them anti-lobes so inspin
petals are lobes whereas anti-spin
pedals are anti-lobes you do wind up
with equivalent numbers of pedals for
anything that we can all agree is a
flower but the kicker that one petal
anti-spin that we can't really do with
the POI it definitely has both a single
lobe and a single anti-lobe so at least
according to Charlie's system for
framing the problem it absolutely fits
so how do we count the Petals of poi
flowers well it totally depends on what
features you're looking for honestly
near as I can tell no one has ever
offered up a single falsifiable
definition for a flower petal so in the
meantime we can argue the merits of all
these different approaches or just
content ourselves with loops arcs lobes
and antelopes your mileage will most
definitely vary want more videos like
this one where I go super deep into POI
Theory math or Frameworks make sure to
like comment share and subscribe to make
sure more people watch this video and
send me requests for other things that
you'd like to learn about
foreign
this video would not be possible if not
for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description help to make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very very generous support
do you like my videos do you like my
flow sessions my Vlogs reviews Combos
and more I am on a mission to try and
bring POI spinning and flow Arts to The
Wider world and help people connect with
their brains and their bodies so please
help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and help me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
and if you'd like to check out some of
my other videos on POI math and Theory
I'll go ahead and leave a link to a
playlist of them down in the description
as well as up here on screen if you are
watching on YouTube also the YouTube
algorithm thinks that you'll like this
top video based upon your past viewing
habits so maybe give that a look as well
thank you so much for watching make sure
to get out and flow today and I'll see
you with a new video on Monday
peace